the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I think I might actually use all 16
colors today oh no this is the most
satisfying day whereas Tuesday was
probably the most mathematically intense
because we developed this equation right
here today is gonna be the most
satisfying because we are going to
cancel out just about every term leaving
a homogeneous infinite reactor
criticality condition so we will go over
today how do you go from this to what is
criticality in a reactor so I want to
get a couple of variables up over here
to remind you guys we had this variable
flux of our I Omega T in the number of
neutrons per centimeter squared per
second travelling through something and
we also had its corresponding non
angular dependent term on just R et if
we don't care what angle things go
through we've got a corresponding
variable called current so I'll put this
as flux we have current J R Omega T and
it's corresponding we don't care about
angle form and today what we're gonna do
is first go over this equation again so
that we understand all of its parts and
there are more parts here than are in
the reading if you remember that's
because I wanted to show you how all of
these terms are created just about every
one of these terms except the external
source and the flow through some surface
has the form of some multiplier times
the integral over all possible variables
that we care about times a reaction rate
D stuff where this reaction rate is
always going to be some cross-section
times some flux so when you look at this
equation using that template it's
actually not so bad so let's go through
each of these pieces right here and then
we're going to start simplifying things
and this boards going to look like
something
rainbow explosion but all that's gonna
be left is a much simpler form of the
neutron diffusion equation so we've got
our time dependent term right here where
I've stuck in this variable flux instead
of the number of neutrons n because we
know that flux is the number of neutrons
times the speed V at which they're
moving and just to check our units flux
should be in neutrons per centimeter
squared per second and n is in neutrons
per cubic centimeter and velocity is in
centimeters per second so the unit's
check out that's why I made that
substitution right there and this way
everything is in terms of little Phi the
flux we have our first term here I think
I'll have a labeling color that'll make
things a little easier to understand
which is due to a regular old fission in
this case we have knew the number of
neutrons created per fission times Chi
the sort of the fission births spectrum
or at what energy the neutrons are born
over 4pi to account for all different
angles in which they could go out times
the integral over our whole control
volume and all other energies and angles
if you remember now we're trying to
track the number of neutrons in some
small Energy Group e traveling in some
small direction Omega and those have
little vector things on it at some
specific position as a function of time
so in order to figure out how many
neutrons are entering our group from
fission we need to know what are all
divisions happening in all the other
groups
I've also escalated this problem a
little bit to not assume that the
reactors homogeneous so I've added an R
or a spatial dependence for every cross
section here which means that as you
move through the reactor you might
encounter different materials you almost
certainly will unless your reactors been
in a blender so it except for that case
you would actually have different cross
sections in different parts of the
reactor so all of a sudden this is
starting to get awfully interesting or
messy depending on what
want to think about it there's the
external source which is actually a real
phenomenon because reactors do stick in
those californium kickstarter sources so
for some amount of time there is an
external source of neutrons giving them
out with some positional energy angle
and time dependence so let's call this
the Kickstarter source there's this term
right here the n i n reactions so these
are other reactions where it's absorb a
neutron and give off anywhere between 2
& 4 neutrons beyond that there it's just
not energetically possible in a fission
reactor but don't undergo fission they
have their own cross-sections their own
birth spectrum and I've stuck in
something right here if we're summing
over all possible I where you have this
reaction D and I an reaction where one
Neutron goes in and I neutrons come out
you've got to multiply by the number of
neutrons per reaction for fission that
was new for an ni n reaction that's just
AI but otherwise the term looks the same
you have your multiplier your birth
spectrum your 4pi your integral over
stuff your unique cross-section and the
flux and these two together give you a
reaction rate I've just written all of
the differentials as D stuff because it
takes a lot of time to write those over
and over again and then we have our
photo fission term where gamma rays of
sufficiently high energy can also induce
fission external to the neutrons the
term looks exactly the same there's
going to be some new for photo fission
some birth spectrum for photo fission
some cross-section for photo fission and
the same flux that we're using
everywhere else then we had what's
called the in scattering term where
neutrons can undergo scattering lose
some energy and enter our group from
somewhere else
that's why we have those Ian Omega
Prime's because it's some other energy
and we have to account for all of those
energy groups that's why we have this
integral there and it looks very much
the same there's a scattering
cross-section and those should actually
be it should be an e Prime right there
make sure I'm not missing any more of
those inside the integral that's all
good
that's a prime good there's also a flux
and then there was this probability
function that a given Neutron starting
off at energy E prime Omega prime ends
up scattering into our energy in Omega
so this would be the other one and this
would be our group but otherwise the
term looks very much the same and that
takes care of all the possible gains of
neutrons into our group the losses are a
fair bit simpler there's reaction of
absolutely any kind let's say this would
be the total cross-section which says
that if a neutron undergoes any reaction
at all it's going to lose energy and go
out of our energy group de notice here
that these are all these energies and
omegas are all our group because we only
care about how many neutrons in our
group undergo a reaction and leaf and
the form is very simple integrate over
volume energy in and Direction times a
cross section times the flux just like
all the other ones then the only
difference and one right here is what
we'll call leakage these are neutrons
moving out of whatever control surface
that we're looking at and this can be
some arbitrarily complex control surface
in 3d I don't really know how to draw a
blob in 3d but at every point on that
glob there's going to be a normal vector
and you can then take the current of
neutrons traveling out that normal
vector and figure out how much of that
is actually leaving our surface DS the
one problem we had is that everything
here is in terms of volume volume volume
surface so we don't have all the same
terms because once we have everything in
the same variables we can start to make
some pretty crazy simplifications the
last thing we did is we invoked the
divergence theorem that says that the
surface integral of some variable f DS
is the same as the volume integral of
the divergence of that variable DV so I
remember there was some snickering last
time because you probably haven't seen
this since was it 1801 or 1802 1802 okay
that makes sense because divergence
usually has more than one variable
associated with it I'll include the dot
because that's what makes it divergence
so we can then rewrite this term let's
start our simplification colors that's
our divergence theorem so let's get rid
of it in this form and call it minus
integral over all that stuff then we'll
have del dot little J to be careful R
Omega T so for every step I'm going to
use a different color so you can see
which simplification led to how much
crossing stuff out and so like I said
this board is gonna look like a rainbow
explosion but then we'll rewrite it at
the end and it's gonna look a whole lot
simpler so now let's start making some
simplifications let's say you're an
actual reactor designer and all you care
about is how many neutrons are here of
the variables here which one do you
think we care the least about
angle I mean do we really care which
direction the neutrons are going no we
pretty much care where are they and are
they causing fission or getting absorbed
so let's start our simplification board
and in blue neglect angle this is where
it starts to get fun so in this case we
will just perform the Omega integral
over all angles we just neglect angle
here we forget the Omega integral forget
Omega there away goes the 4 pi because
we've integrated over all 4 pi star ad
ins or all solid angle and let's just
keep going
forget the 4 pi forget the Omega forget
the Omega forget the 4 PI and the Omega
and the Omega same thing here
forget the Omega in the scattering
kernel forget it in the flux forget it
there forget it there and there as well
okay we've now completely eliminated one
variable and all we had to do is ditch
the for PI's and one of the integrals
what next we're tracking right now every
possible position every possible energy
at every possible time if you want to
know what is your flux going to be in
the reactor at steady state what
variable do you attack next yep time so
let's just say this reactor is at steady
state that's going to invoke a few
things for one it's going to ditch the
entire steady state term we're gonna get
rid of all the T's in all the fluxes
this shouldn't take too long to do I
think that's all of them and the third
thing is if this reactor is at steady
state chances are we've taken our
Kickstarter source out because we just
needed it to get it going but the
reactor should be self-sustaining once
it's at steady state so let's just get
rid of our source term so you just want
to make sure I didn't miss any here okay
next up go with green what else do you
think we can simplify about this problem
well if you look far enough away from
the reactor we can make an assumption
that the reactor is roughly homogeneous
in some cases it's not so good of an
assumption like very close to anything
that has a huge absorption cross-section
now I want to explain the physics behind
this if the neutrons travel a very long
distance through any group of materials
then those materials will appear to be
roughly homogeneous to the neutrons if
however the neutrons travel through
something that's very different from the
materials around it then that
homogeneous assumption breaks down so in
what locations in a nuclear reactor do
you think you cannot treat the system is
homogeneous where do the properties of
materials suddenly change by a huge
amount yeah Luke control rods right so
let's say it's bad for control rods
where else
how about the fuel all of a sudden
you're moving from a bunch of structural
materials where Sigma fission equals
zero to the fuel where Sigma fission
like you saw in the test can be like
five hundred barns which even though
it's got a very small exponent in front
of it ten to the minus 22 centimeters
squared it's still pretty significant so
this assumption breaks down around the
control rods and around the fuel but we
can get around this let's analyze the
simplest crazy as possible reactor which
would be a molten salt fueled reactor
it's just a blob of 700 Celsius goo
that's got its fuel coolant and control
rods all built in so if we assume that
the reactor is homogeneous which is a
pretty good assumption for molten salt
fueled reactors because the fuels
dissolved in the coolant and it builds
up its own fission product poisons so
it's got some of its own control rods
kind of built in usually will have other
extra ones too but whatever then we can
start to really simplify things if we
get rid of any homogeneity assumptions
we cannot necessarily get rid of the R
in the flux because even if the reactors
homogeneous it still might have
boundaries so you might be able to
approximate it as just a cylinder or a
slab of uniform materials but if we were
to get rid of the R's in the flux term
that would mean that as we graph flux as
a function of distance it would look
like that
including infinitely far away from the
reactor and now is that true absolutely
not so I don't want to leave that up for
anyone we'll fill in what these graphs
look like a little later just leave them
there for now we can get rid of some of
the other ARS though like these
cross-sections if the reactor is
actually homogeneous then the
cross-section is the same everywhere
because the materials are the same
everywhere so we can get rid of the ARS
here the R's here and there and there
and that's it I think don't think I
missed any good next up if this reactors
homogeneous then does it really matter
at which location were taking this
balance does it really matter which
little volume element we're looking at
we say these equations are will call
them volume identical which means if
this same equation is satisfied at any
point in the reactor we don't need to do
the volume integral over the whole
reactor it's not like it's gonna change
anywhere we go so forget the volume
integrals hopefully you guys see where
I'm going with this and I've never I've
never tried teaching it like this
rainbow explosion before but I'm kind of
excited to see how it turns out
so already like 2/3 of the stuff that we
had written are gone what's the only
variable left that we can go after and
what's the only color left that I
haven't really used energy yeah so we
can make a couple of us different
assumptions this equation as it is is
not yet really analytically solvable
because a lot of these energy dependent
terms don't have analytical solutions or
even forms like the cross-sections but
we can start attacking energy hopefully
this is different enough from white yeah
is that big enough difference for you
guys to see good ok we can start doing
this in a few different ways I want to
mention what they are and then we're
gonna do the easiest one
so the way it's done for real like in
the computational reactor physics group
is you can discretize the energy
discretize the energy into a bunch of
little energy groups so you can write
this equation for every little energy
group and assume that along this energy
scale ranging from your maximum energy
to probably thermal energy yeah oh to
five okay let's do this clearly with
thick chalk there we go
you can then discretize into some little
energy group let's say that's eg I
that's eg I plus one and so on and so on
and depending on the type of reactor
that you're looking at and the energy
resolution that you need you choose the
number of energy groups accordingly does
anyone happen to know for a light water
reactor how many energy groups do you
think we need to model a light water
reactor the answer might surprise you
it's just two actually all we care about
so let's say this would be for the
general case all we care about for a
light water reactor is are your neutrons
thermal or are they not because the
neutrons that are not thermal are not
contributing to fission that much they
are just a little bit and you can
account for those but pretty much
they're not once the neutrons slow down
to get thermal in the range from like
let's say about an e V to that
temperature took a surprising amount of
time to write with sidewalk chalk then
you've got things that are about 500 or
a thousand times more likely to undergo
fission and so all you care about is the
neutrons are all born they're all born
right about here and they scatter
and bounce around and you don't care
because they're just in this not thermal
region and when they enter the thermal
region you start tracking them because
those are the ones that really count for
fission and if you actually look up the
specifications for the ap1000 this is a
modern reactor under construction in
many different places in the world when
you see how do they do the neutronic
analysis two group approximation so this
isn't just an academic exercise to make
it easier for sophomores to understand
this is actually something that's done
for real reactors so if you ever felt
like I'm making it too simple no no this
is I'm simplifying it down to what's
really done and I will get you that
specification so you can see what
westinghouse says like this is how we
design the reactor we made a two group
simplification in many cases so you can
discretize you can forget it
which we're going to call the one group
approximation or you can well let's say
two group is the other one that we're
actually gonna tackle we're gonna do
this one forget energy but we're not
really going to forget energy because
you can't just pick an energy and pick a
cross-section and say okay that's the
cross-section we're going to use if most
cross-sections have the following form
if this is log of energy and this is log
of Sigma and it goes something like that
what energy do you pick go ahead tell me
which energy do you pick anyone want to
wager a guess
the ones before after the big squigglies
I don't think that's correct because if
you do it this then you're gonna weigh
underestimate vision if you do it here
you're gonna weigh overestimate vision
or whatever rank we have the reaction
you have we didn't say which reaction
this is the rest of you who are silent
and afraid to speak up you're actually
correct I wouldn't actually pick any
single value here what you need to do is
find some sort of average cross-section
for whatever reaction that accurately
represents the number of reactions
happening in the system and in order to
do that you have to come up with some
average cross-section for whatever
reaction you have by integrating over
your whole energy range of the energy
dependent cross-section as a function of
energy times your flux de over this look
familiar from 1801 or two as well what's
the average value of some function a
little bit well we'll bring it back here
now so retrieve it from cold storage in
your memories because this is how actual
cross-sections are averaged for whatever
energy range you're picking you know
what I'm gonna make this a little more
general I won't say zero I'll just say
your minimum energy for your group so
now this equation is general for the
multi group and the one group and two
group method for whatever cross-section
you want to pick and whatever energy
range you're looking at you take the
actual data and perform an average for
the fast and thermal delineation where
let's say this is fast and this is
thermal you would have two different
averages maybe this average would be
right there you know what let's use
white so it actually has some contrast
so this would be one value of the
cross-section and maybe the next average
would be right there so you simplify
this absolutely non analytical
form of your complicated cross-section
to just a couple of values maybe we'll
call that average Sigma fast and we'll
call that average Sigma thermal
so using this analogy and this color we
can then say we're gonna take an average
new an average CAI get rid of the
energies because we can perform the same
energy average integration on every
quantity with energy dependence so all
we do is we put a bar there ditch the
energies
it's the energies and let's just say
that flux is going to be what it is
same thing here yeah same thing there
and there and there they're there
they're here and here and here and
there's a cross-section there's an
energy there's an energy there is a
cross-section we don't care about those
anymore and there's a couple of other
implications of this energy
simplification what is the birth
spectrum now what's the probability that
a neutron is born in our energy group
which contains all energies one yeah
okay so forget the Chi and that one and
that one and what about this scattering
kernel what's the probability that a
neutron scatters from any other energy
which is already in our group into our
group which contains all energies yeah
scattering no longer matters when you do
the one group approximation because if
the neutron loses some of its energy
it's still in our energy group because
our energy group contains all energies
so forget the scattering kernel and
forget the energy integrals what are we
actually left with not much there's no
green in here yet good because I need to
do one more thing there is no more green
oh we did green we did time okay green
red
orange is if the orange I used damn it
okay we've used those purple no we've
used that oh my god we've used both
blues bright yellow yeah yes
chi is the fission birth spectrum the
probability that a neutron is born at
any given energy but because all
neutrons are born in our energy group
which contains all energies then that
just becomes one and goes away there's
there's no birth spectrum because
they're just born in our group yes that
makes sense yeah
okay I think I found the reaction we'll
only color besides black on a black
chalkboard and white which we already
have that I have left we also have a
slightly darker shade of gray but I'm
literally out this worked out awesome
because there's one more thing that we
want to deal with what do we even have
left all right
what is the one term that is not in all
of the same variables as the others that
current that J what do we do about that
so we're going sorry yeah the F e to e
so I'll actually I'll recreate some of
our variables here because there's a lot
of them so our F of e prime to e is
what's called the scattering kernel and
that's the probability that a neutron
scatters from some other energy Group E
Prime in two hours in a about de and Chi
of e is the fission birth spectrum
and just for completeness knew of e is
our Neutron multiplier or neutrons per
fission I think that gives a pretty
complete explanation of what's up here
so now let's figure out how to deal with
the current term this is when we make
one of the biggest approximations here
and go from what's called the neutron
transport equation which is a fully
accurate physical model of what's really
going on to the neutron diffusion
equation and this is where it gets
really fun you don't assume that
neutrons are subatomic particles that
are whizzing about and knocking off of
everything else you then treat the
neutrons kind of like a gas or like a
chemical and you just say that it
follows the laws of diffusion again this
works out very well except for places
where cross sections suddenly change
like near control rods or near fuel but
for most of the reactor especially if we
have a molten salt fuel reactor we can
invoke what's called ficks law this
sound familiar to anyone ficks law of
diffusion three or nine one or five
eleven one it's it is that it's the
change of a chemical on down a density
or concentration gradient so yeah you've
got the idea what ficks law says is that
the current or let's say the diffusion
current or the Neutron current is going
to be equal to some diffusion
coefficient times the gradient of
whatever a chemical concentration you've
got let me put the C in there so right
here this would be the current I'll
label in a different color
this would be your variable of interest
maybe C is for concentration or Phi is
for flux oh that reminds me where are
those bars on our flux which term did we
do energy whereas my slightly
blue over here all of these Phi's become
Capitol because we've gotten rid of all
the angular and energy in everything
dependence Oh angular dependence neglect
Omega that should be dark blue mega goes
away
and the flux has become capital so many
terms to keep track of luckily you will
never have to and then the J becomes a
capital J miss any Phi's here no because
that one was already gone cool alright
so we can use ficks law and transform
the current into something related to
flux and what we're saying here is that
we're getting rid of the true physics
which is that there's some fixed Neutron
current and we're saying that neutrons
behave kind of like a gas or a chemical
in solution and so in yellow we can
ditch our current related term and
rewrite it we don't have any integrals
left as negative del squared Phi I think
the only variable left is our not too
bad now we have a second order linear
differential equation describing the
flow of neutrons in this system it's we
actually have something that we can
solve for flux I think it's time to
rewrite it wouldn't you say this has
been fun so
let's rewrite what's left actually see
everything there will write it in boring
old white so we have no transient
dependence and we have left Sigma
fission times flux as a function of our
no source and we have our Neutron and I
n reactions of oh we forgot our new
Sigma fission then we have our I Sigma
fission from n I n times flux next term
we have photo fission so we have a new
from gamma rays times Sigma fission from
gamma rays times flux next up we have
well last last simplification to make we
have scattering and we have total
cross-section when we said forget about
energy and our scattering kernel becomes
one and that's light blue gonna make one
more modification to this board do we
care about scattering at all anymore
whatsoever because scattering doesn't
change the number of neutrons left so we
can then take these two terms and just
call it Sigma absorption times flux
because if we take scattering minus the
total cross-section it's like saying all
that's left if you don't scatter is you
absorb and if you remember all add to
the energy pile we said that our total
cross-section is scattering plus
absorption and absorption could be
vision and capture and capture could be
lets say capture with nothing happens
Plus these end I and reactions plus any
other capture reaction that does
something so we're going to use this
cross section identity right here with a
couple of minus signs on it and say well
scattering minus total leaves you with
negative absorption to simplify terms
I'll leave that up there for everyone to
see so then we have scattering and total
just becomes minus Sigma absorption
times Phi of R and we're left with what
was that current that becomes plus
there's Adi missing in there isn't there
a yellow D minus D okay and that's it
yes
D is the diffusion coefficient right
here so we're assuming that neutrons
diffused like a gas or a chemical with
some diffusion coefficient and so we'll
define what that is Oh probably next
class because we have seven minutes yeah
Luke
uh-huh the see right here that's
whatever variable we're tracking so
let's call that flux or let's call it an
the number of neutrons because flux is
just number of neutrons times velocity
so let's say that the concentration was
the concentration of neutrons and we
just multiplied by their velocity to get
flux so it's almost like we can say that
the concentration of neutrons is
directly related to the flux and that
way we have everything in flux and
that's the entire Neutron diffusion
equation yep this is for one group with
all the assumptions we made right here
homogeneous what other assumptions did
we make steady state and we already
neglected that and I think that's enough
qualifiers for this but it's directly
from this equation right here that we
can develop what's called our
criticality condition under what
conditions is the reactor critical so
then in this case by critical we're
gonna have some variable called K
effective which defines whether that's
defines the number of neutrons produced
over the number of neutrons consumed and
if K effective equals 1 then we say that
the reactor is critical that means that
exactly the number of neutrons produced
by regular fission ni n reactions and
photo fission equals exactly the number
of neutrons absorbed in the anything and
that leaked out
so let's relabeled our terms in the same
font that we did here so this would be
the fission term this would be n i n
reactions
this would be photo fission this would
be absorption this would be leakage how
many neutrons get out of our finite
boundary and if you remember when we
started out we said we're gonna make the
neutron balance equation equal to gains
minus losses and through our rainbow
explosion simplification we've done
exactly that these are your gains these
are your losses when gains minus losses
equals zero the reactors in perfect
balance yep leakage comes out to be
negative
despite the plus sign here and that's
actually intentional
that's because neutrons travel down the
concentration gradient so let's say
we're gonna draw an imaginary flux
spectrum that's gonna be quite correct
and I'm doing all of those features for
a reason but let's look at the
concentration gradient right here
leakage is positive when your flux
gradient is negative that's why the sign
is flipped right there so a positive
diffusion term means you have neutrons
leaking out down a negative
concentration gradient because if you
look at the slope here the change in X
is positive and the change in flux is
negative so the slope is negative
concentration gradients negative that's
why the sign is the opposite of what you
may expect and the same thing goes for
chemical or gaseous or any other kind of
diffusion that's come glad you asked
because that's always a point of
confusion is why is there that plus sign
that's intentional and that's correct
cool so it's in yeah Sean
in that case if you really explicitly
write our losses would it be -
absorption let's put some parentheses on
here equals zero and a minus and when we
say plus leakage we have that plus sign
in there so I'm not gonna put any
parentheses up here because that
wouldn't be correct but what I can say
is that gains minus losses have to be in
perfect balance to have a K effective
equal to one anyone else have any
questions before I continue the
explanation cool let's say you're
producing more neutrons than you're
destroying that's what we call
supercritical so I just did an interview
for this K through 12 outreach program
and they said should be people be afraid
when something quote-unquote goes
critical
sounds scary emotionally right and the
answer is absolutely not if your reactor
goes critical it's turned on and it's in
perfect balance that's exactly what you
want so going critical is not a scary
thing it means we have control if
something goes supercritical it doesn't
necessarily mean it's out of control
reactors can be very slightly
supercritical and still in control
because of what's called delayed
neutrons which I will not introduce
today because we have two minutes if a
reactor has a K effective of less than 1
we call that subcritical so it's
important to note that the the nuclear
terminology that's kind of leaked out
into our vernacular is not physically
correct in the way that it's used words
like critical or me are used to incite
emotions and bring about fear when to a
nuclear engineer critical means in
perfect control in balance like you
would expect are in equilibrium that all
sounds kind of nice makes you calm down
a little bit yeah so we can put one last
term in front of our criticality
condition we can take either the gains
or the losses move the equal sign and
zero over a little bit
and put a 1 over K effective here this
then perfectly describes the difference
between the gains and the losses in a
reactor so if the gains equal the losses
then k effective must equal 1 and the
reactor has got to be in balance if
there are more gains than losses which
means if you are producing more neutrons
than you're consuming then k effective
must be greater than 1 for this equation
to still equal zero because this
equation must be satisfied so if you're
making more neutrons your k effectives
got to be greater than 1 so you have a
less than 1 multiplier in front and on
the opposite side if you're losing more
neutrons than you're gaining your K
effective has to be less than 1 to make
this equation balanced going along with
all these definitions right here so it's
exactly 505 of I've given you delivered
promised blackboard of Lucky Charms and
we've hit perfect spot which is the one
group homogeneous steady-state neutron
diffusion equation from which we can
develop our criticality conditions and
solve this much simpler equation to get
the flux profiles that I've started to
draw here so I want to stop here and
take any questions on any of the terms
you see here yeah
the disparate energy groups and then
when we're doing the one group you're
actually just treating sperm one fast
together we are that's right yep so a
lot of reactors at least thermal
reactors where you only care if neutrons
are thermal or not two groups enough
when you have a one group or a two group
equation these are fairly analytically
solvable things and get to any more
groups than that and yes they're
analytically solvable but it gets
horrible and that's why we have
computers to do the sorts of repetitive
calculations over and over again once
we've solved the one group equation I'll
then show you intuitive ways to write
but not solve the equations for multi
group equations sure any other questions
so like I promise we didn't stay complex
for long because there's basically
nothing left yeah oh that's a partial
derivatives yep that yeah there we go
yeah so this is saying a change in
Neutron population or the partial
derivative of n with respect to T cuz n
varies with space energy angle time and
anything else you could possibly think
about equals the gains minus the losses
I think this is worthy of a t-shirt if
any of you guys would like to update the
department shirts to properly take into
account photo fission external sources
and ni n reactions I think it would make
for a much more impressive thing because
we kind of printed an oversimplification
before it's too bad and we definitely
had room on the shirt there was like
room on the sides and on the sleeves
yeah keep going on that might have to be
long-sleeved I think they'll be pretty
soon yeah okay if no one else has any
immediate questions you'll have plenty
of time tomorrow because the whole goal
tomorrow is gonna be to solve this
equation that's only gonna take like 20
minutes so we can do a quick review of
the simplification of the neutron
transport equation solve the neutron
diffusion equation if you have questions
we'll spend time to answer them there
and if you don't we'll move on to
writing multi group equations and also
Friday for recitation it's electron
microscope time so now that you guys
have learned different electron
interactions with matter you're going to
see them so we're going to be analyzing
a couple of different pieces of
materials that a couple of you are gonna
get to select and we're going to image
them with electrons to show how you can
beat the wavelength of light imaging
limit like I told you before we're gonna
produce our own x-ray spectra to analyze
them elementally where you'll see the
bremsstrahlung you'll see the
characteristic Peaks and you'll see a
couple of other features that I'll
explain too so get ready for some SEM
tomorrow